-We don't always
have enough time
to cover all of the recent news.
So, here with a recap is one
of our writers, Amber Ruffin,
in a segment we call
"Amber Says What."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You guys!
Things have been crazy!
Okay, first of all, you know
that creep Brett Kavanaugh?
Well, I heard that
when he was in college,
he started a bar fight,
and I was like, "What?"
Then I heard it happened
after a UB40 concert,
and I was like, "What?"
Then I heard UB40 was a reggae
band that looks like this,
and I was like, "What?"
Then I saw a video of a man
proposing to his girlfriend
on "Jeopardy!"
and I was like, "What?"
It was so cute.
He proposed, and then they
went to her with a microphone,
and she said, "What is yes?"
[ Laughter ]
It made me so happy because
if you propose like that
and you answer like that,
you are going to be together
forever.
And being together forever means
watching a lot of "Jeopardy!"
Then Kanye changed his name
to Ye, and I was like, "Boo."
[ Laughter, applause ]
Then...
Oh, you too?
I guess everyone dislikes him.
Then everyone told me
I should watch this political ad
making the rounds,
and I was like, "What?"
Then the people in the ad
were like, "We hate Paul.
Paul is terrible."
And I was like, "What?"
Then, one by one, the people
in the ad were like,
"Paul is my brother!"
And I was like, "What?!"
This man's siblings went on TV
to tell people
to vote for his opponent.
I saw that and I was like
[Laughs] "What?"
Then I was like, "Wait,
Paul's a Republican, right?"
And he was, so I was like
[Laughs] "What?"
Then at a rally, Trump said he,
"Fell in love with Kim Jong-un."
And I was like, "What?
Y'all in love?"
Seems right.
You're a dictator.
He's a dictator.
Your [bleep] looks like a tater.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Just kidding.
Because according to
Stormy Daniels' new book,
it looks like Toad
from Super Mario.
Yeah, that's right.
It looks like Toad
from "Mario Party."
And I was like, "Why would you
ruin 'Mario Party' for me?"
Yes, I'm a grown-ass woman
who plays "Mario Party."
Shut up!
And then Facebook had
a data breach this weekend,
and I was like,
"What...else is new?"
Doesn't this happen monthly?
What are they hoping to get?
More pictures of my cat?
E-mail me, and you can have 'em!
Just kidding.
I don't have a cat.
Because if you can't
use the toilet,
you can't be in my house.
Then the Philadelphia Flyers
unveiled their new mascot,
Gritty,
and I was like,
"What the [bleep] is that?"
See, that's why
I don't have cats.
Because they cough something up,
and the next thing you know,
that thing they coughed up
becomes a mascot.
Then Bill Cosby got 3 to 10
years for sexual assault,
and I was like, "What?
He actually got jail time?
Well, I have lost a bet."
Then I read that while Cosby
was in jail,
someone threw a hot dog bun
at him,
and I was like,
"Hmm, can I laugh at that?
He's an old man who can't see
and is in jail."
Then I pictured
what that would look like,
and I laughed my butt off
'cause it looked like this.
Oh!
[ Laughs ]
It's fine.
Then someone was like,
"Will Smith is bungee jumping
from a helicopter
in the Grand Canyon,"
and I was like, "What?
Who did what
from the what in the world?"
People were like,
"It's for his 50th birthday,"
and I was like, "What? He's 50?"
Then I Googled "Men in Black"
and found out
it came out in 1997.
And I was like, "What?"
Then I looked in the mirror and
I was like, "Oh, no, I got old.
Yet somehow more beautiful."
[ Laughter ]
Then --
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughs ]
You're why I behave so poorly!
Then Trump held
a press conference
at what I assume was a flag farm
and said this.
-China has total respect
for Donald Trump
and for Donald Trump's
very, very large brain.
-[ Laughs ]
And I was like, "What?"
I realized that man is in charge
and I felt terrible.
But then I pictured this
and felt better.
[ Laughs ]
This has been "Amber Says What."
[ Cheers and applause ]